el papá empezó el día con una visita
considerada histórica unidad cuando
viajó a la ciudad de nayaf y caminó
hacia por esas callejuelas a encontrarse
ayatolá alí sistaní la figura del
chiísmo más importante también la figura
religiosa más importante él ha apoyado
democracia en el 2005 también fue a
quien dio esa factura en el 2014 cuando
hice se ha tomado una tercera parte del
país para que los jóvenes y los hombres
de este país se adjuntarán con las
fuerzas armadas y lucharán para detener
el avance del estado islámico el papa
sostuvo una conversación en la colaron
de de proteger a los cristianos de esta
nación y luego se dirigió hasta aquí
hasta donde nos encontramos aún en el
sur de irak que es la cuna de abraham el
padre de las tres religiones del libro y
se reunió con líderes de las etnias y de
las religiones de esta parte del país
bienvenido y
desde bagdad en un mensaje de
fraternidad y convivencia muy simbólico
en el cual les pide también a ellos que
ayuden a proteger a estas minorías que
viven en el país